على كل المزيد معنا من الجزائر عبر سكايب
خالد ضرارنه ممثل منظمه مراسلون بلا حدود
في شمال افريقيا اهلا بك استاذ خالد بدايه
هل لك ان تعطينا فكره وتقييم عن وضع
الصحفيين في الداخل السوداني الان
مساء الخير لكم وضعيه الصحفيين السودانيين
اليوم داخل البلاد مقلقه للغايه منذ بدايه
هذه الازمه السياسيه والامنيه في السودان
هناك العديد من الصحفيين الذين تعرضوا
لاعتداءات مباشره او غير مباشره هناك
اعتداء ضد مواكب صحفيه ضد الصحفيين هو
مراسلون
لقنوات عربيه ايضا يعني حاولوا القيامه
بمهامهم الحمد لله الى حد الان ليس هناك
جرحى ولا قتله ونحن مراسله بلا حدود دائما
مستعده لتقديم يد العون لكل الصحفيين
والمراسلون المتواجدون في السودان من
تحملون المسؤوليه لمن اي جهه
المسؤوليه لكل الاطراف السياسيه في
السودان لاننا نحن نعتقد بان كل الاطراف
في السودان لها مسؤوليه حول ما يمكن ان
يجرى للمدنيين وخاصه للصحفيين بما اننا
نحن نهتم بوضع الصحفيين وامنهم في السودان
وفي كل ارجاء العالم الاع التي وقعت في
هذه الايام هي اعتداءات يعني
اختلفت من طرف العديد من الاطراف الطرف
المسلح الرسمي في السودان والاطراف الاخرى
ونحن حاولنا التواصل مع كل هذه الاطراف
لنجعل لنفهمهم شيء اساسي بان حريه الصحفي
وامنه يجب ان يكون من اولويات السلطات
السودانيه وكل الاطراف المتنازعه في
السودان ذكرت اعتداء واحد على مواكب
للصحفيين هل من اعتداءات اخرى يمكن رصدها
والحديث عنها لانه قلت بطريقه مباشره وغير
مباشره نتحدث عن التخويف عن ماذا
اكيد هناك تخويف العديد من الصحفيين هناك
اطراف سياسيه وعسكريه ومسلحه في السودان
لا تترك الصحفيين يؤدون مهامهم ولا تتركهم
يغطون هنا التهديدات كثيره طبعا علاوه على
العشرات من الصحفيين الذين كانوا محجوزين
في فنادق وفي اماكن مغلقه بدون طعام وبدون
شرب لمده ايام طويله جدا في مراسم بلا
حدود نددنا بهذه الوضعيه منذ اول يوم ونحن
اليوم نحاول ان نتصل مع كل اطراف
السودانيه ومع الاوساط الصحفيه ونحن لا
نتواصل مع نقابه الصحفيين السودانيين من
اجل مساعده الصحفيين والمراسلين في
السودان عبر ارسالهم مثلا يعني الخضات او
الستائر او اي نوع من المساعدات تكون
مباشره او غير مباشره ارسلتم او ست
اعتقد بان هناك عمليات اجلاء تمت لمواطنين
عرب بما فيهم بعض الصحفيين نحن لسنا دخل
مباشر لان هذه القضيه تخص الحكومات ونعتقد
بانها هناك دول من شمال افريقيا مثلا قامت
باجلاء بعض المواطنين من بينهم ربما اقل
من 10 صحفيين نحن دورنا ليس الاجلاء دورنا
هو المساعده والمسانده بكل ما يمكن ان
نفعل من ذلك ونحن بدانا في ذلك مراسلون
بلا حدود تساند الصحافه السودانيه منذ
سنوات وسنوات قبل بدايه هذه الاضطرابات
وقبل حتى
الانقلاب العسكري الذي قام به البرهان
فنحن نواصل عملنا وعملنا اليوم في الميدان
اصعب مما كان عليه من قبل
كيف هو عمل الصحافيين داخل السودان خلال
فترات الازمات وهل بال
فتره الان ام انه لا لازال على حاله
التقرير السنوي لمناسبه بلا حدود سيخرج
بعد ثلاثه ايام سينشر وسترون كلكم بان
هناك تدهور كبير لحريه الصحافه في دول
شمال افريقيا بما فيها السودان لان هذا
البلد عرف كما تعرفين انقلاب عسكري من
خلال هذا الانقلاب تدهورت كثيرا حريه
الصحافه وحريه الصحفيين في هذا البلد ونحن
كل يوم نرى بان هناك اعتداءات الصحفيين
وصحافيين سودانيين ومراسلين اجانب ونددنا
بذلك في كل البيانات التي نقدمها من اجل
ان نفهم السلطات السودانيه على انها يجب
ان تجعل من امن وسلامه الصحفيين اولويه
كبرى ومنذ لاجيب عن سؤالك منذ بدايه هذه
الازمه السياسيه والامنيه لاحظنا بان اولا
هناك
نداءات كثيره لصحافيين سودانيين يطلبون
منا المساعده ان كانت مساعده اجتماعيه او
مساعده امنيه فنحن طبعا هناك نساعدهم اولا
عن ضمان امنهم في هذه الظروف الصعبه ونحن
نساعد
ونقدم تدريبات للصحفيين بما فيهم الصحفيين
سودانيين ليعرفون كيف يتعاملون في اوقات
صعبه مثل هذه من الحروب الاهليه او
النزاعات المسلحه بهذه المرحله تحديدا ما
اكثر ما يخيفكم وبالمقابل عمليه تقييد
حركه ووصول الصحفي الى المعلومه ماذا تعني
طبعا ما يخيفنا اليوم الاكثر هو ان ان
يجرح صحفي او يقتل صحفي هذا هذه اكبر
المخاوف التي لنا نحن في مراسلون بلا حدود
لذلك فنحن لا ننتخر اي جهد من اجل ان نفهم
الصحفيين على ان املهم اهميه قصوى وعليهم
ان لا ياخذون وعليهم ان لا يغامرون ابدا
بحياتهم لان الوضع السياسي والامني صعب
جدا وخطير للغايه في السودان فهدفنا الاول
هو السلامه الصحفي ان لا نسمع اليوم او
غدا ان يكون هناك جريحه او قتله وطبعا
المساعده الثانيه هو المساعد الصحفيين في
تاقلم مع هذه الوضعيه الامنيه الصعبه من
اجل الوصول الى المعلومه نقدم مساعدات عده
من طرف مراسل بلا حدود نحن على تواصل مع
الصحفيين نحن على تواصل ايضا مع بعض
السلطات الرسميه في السودان لما تقبل
الاجابه عن اسئلتنا وعن مخاوفنا نتمنى
السلامه للجميع من الجزائر عبر سكايب كان
معنا خالد ضرار نام ممثل منظمه مراسلون
بلا حدود في شمال افريقيا شكرا جزيلا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات